Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Muddy Heights 2.
Now yes, this is a sequel to a poop game...
Literally just a poop game...
A game about poop.
Anyway... so...
This came out a while ago and I meant to play it before, and apparently there's three levels
of which you can get a STAR GOLDEN FOR POOPING on everybody's dreams!
But I don't know how to do that just yet, so we're going to find out...
...probably very similar to the first in which you're standing on a rooftop
looking down on everyone- why is everyone wearing a poop shirt?
What is it about this town and poop?!
WHY DOES EVERYBODY LIKE POOP SO MUCH?!
I mean I would be assuming that they would be eating poop except I know that they're just going to
POOP OUT THE POOP ANYWAY!!!!!!
Ohhh look at you! You look so nice and not very stressed right now
but you're gonna be very stressed very soon!
3 more lives? I don't have the money for that.
SO LETS GO POOP!
WHOOA!
WHOA GOD!
Okay?
So habooski?
Ohh
Do I have control of this? Not quite. Okay... little bouncy on this poop.
Sorry.. sorry... SORRY!
Sorry, SORRY!!
Still going? Apparently? EW god...
10 COMBO! YEAHHH!
I did my goal!
I don't know why I'm still able to control this poop.
What kind of demon did I eat that I was actually able to have manual control over
where my poop goes??
And the kind of shit that it does to devastate the village.
So I got one moneys...
I- I don't know how to do the moneys.
So...
"Longer poop duration," "bigger splatters," "double jump," "faster speed," "higher jump," "explode with 'F'..."
"Longer combo time." Alright let's do that.
Everyone knows tjat corn is not digestible so that it-d-d-d-eats to...
some bullshit about... poop.
"ahhh"
Boink.
Oh no!
The devastation...
The "poopastation"...
The "devapooption"...
I don't know...
HUUBBBOWSKY!
Oh "going home."
There's a truck dedicated to poop. Everybody's license plate is 'poo-oop'
Why?
It doesn't make any goddamn sense!
Excuse me, were you eating this?
I have no idea.. there's probably some secrets that I probably should know about- ahh...
Found a secret! "Music Mishap!" I don't know how I di-did that
What did I did?
Okay
YYYEEEEAAAA-
Bubblegum "double jump." Mmmyeah I'll go for that.
Lets go poop!
Uh...
'Kay so I need to ruin 5 dinners.
BOINK!
BOOP-I-DOOP!
Oh no!
WOOP!
Ruin dinner.
Ruin this dinner, ruin that dinner
WOOP!
Ruin this dinner!
Ruin that dinner!
Ok I gotta go to the other side....
(sing songy) EXCUSE MEEEE PARDON MOOIII
Okay, ruin these dinners
Yeah we did that! Okay that's a thing...
Hey where're you going everybody?
AHHH NO! Aww...
Alright I think we need three more lives, cause otherwise what are we gonna be able to do about all of this?
I'm not gonna be able to do everything.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE ALL OF THE SECRETS ARE, HOW WOULD I KNOW??!!
I DON'T WANNA PLAY THIS GAME-
I DON'T WANNA HAVE...- like encyclopediadic knowledge of this!
That just seems like a horrible way to go...
No pun intended.
*various shitty fart noises per bounce*
There's gotta be a secret back here or something.
Ah! There we are!
Yay! I got a toilet 'pooper!'
WHEEE!
*various shitty fart noises per bounce*
WOO!!!!!
Ah shit.
Literally.
Alright, so somewhere there's more toilet papers but I don't know where....
"Hydro Poop," "Bombs Away," "Fertilizer..."
*gentle fart noise*
All these things, do not understand.
*car screech*
Sorry!
*various shitty fart noises per bounce with people screaming*
Oh I thought that was gonna be it!
*various shitty fart noises per bounce*
WHOO!
Whoa shit, sorry!
Oh jeez! Oookay!
Didn't mean to do that!
Sorry everybody! Sorry! Sorry. Just Markiplier coming through!
Marki-turd *groans*
So where are these other toilet papers..?
*graceful toot*
Probably one is near a side...
.....no?
*many toots and farts per bounce*
Hey bird!
Boink!
AHHH I got you birdie!
So where are these things?
I only got one poop left and I have no idea what I am supposed to be doing...
I don't know where the other teepee is...
Oh it's up there! How am I supposed to get up there????
How in the frick-a-frack do you think I'm going to get up there..?
Goddammit
Eh
EH!
EH!!
EH!!!!!
Sh- dammit, dammit!
(high pitched) Ahhhhhh nooo!
Our last poop here we-NOPE! I guess we're done!!!!
Level complete but I didn't do everything I meant to do.
Might as well go to the next level because I got nothing else better to do about this.
THAN TAKE A SHIT ON THE WORLD THAT I HATE!!!!!!!
EVERYONE ON HERE CAN GO FFFF- FRICK 'EM SELF
I see a toilet paper... ahh I see it's scouting me.
Alright! I know where all the toilet paper are now!
That's handy
Let's do that!
Eh! Little wimpy one!
Ah shit- AHHH COME ON!!!
With the bullshit!!
Hello!!
Swimming pool
Ah huh.
*fart and scream sounds*
WOAH! "Burning Rubber?"
Alrighty then.
*game fart noise*
*Markifart noise*
Okay, so I need to be the DJ which I imagine there's someone doing music over he-
Ah yes of course
Of course
Sorry!
Excuse me! Sorry! And hup!
Mmmbupp!
YEEEAAHHH!!!
Get the music on! Get the shitty shitty club music- wow...
Lady.
H-h-hey! How you doin'?
YEAH!! Op- sorry. She fell for me.
Hi!! *laughs* How you doin'??
*laughs again*
Well.. I'm really glad that this town is very confident with their bodies.
I am VERY excited.
That sounded weird. I'm not excited, I'm proud!
I gotta get these toilet papers! I can get them, I know where they all are!
*fart*
Second one- BOINK! Yeah, there we go!
That's one!!
I know I'm great. HUPP! Hupp!!
Okay, I can get that other one. Sorry! Oh god, I'm so sorry. Ohh I'm sorry.
Ohh you don't wanna take poop as a pre workout.
That's actually a horrible idea.
WOOOO!!! Bouncy!
NOIICCEE!!
Okay I can get this last one. I'm not sure I can get it in time though!
Hupp! Oh shit..
*toot toot*
Goddamnit!
*fart sound*
AHHHH SHIIT!
But I can get the other one, and I can get another score at the same time...
HEP!
HABOOSKI!
Shit
Okay, I can make it from here.
Oh shit! Come onnn!
ep! AHHH!! COME ON!! OH NO! NO! NO! NOOO!! OH GOD... I CAN MAKE IT..
Oh jeez
(gradually gets high pitched) Oh fuck- AHH! No no no no AH!! NO! NOOOOOOO!!!!
(high pitched) GODDAMN YOU SLOW MOTION YOU FUCKED ME! YOU FUCK ME! YOU FUCKED MY SHIT! AH!
Goddammit.
*slightly majestic fart sounds*
There we go, that's what I was looking for
Some ELEVATION ON ME!
There we go, YESS!! Got the toilet paper that's another dollar!
That's another dollar in the bank- ow!
Sorry!
Sorry I gotta cause a panic real quick..
Shit
EVERYBODY GET OFF THE DANCE FLOOR! AHH
Okay they should slip, a lot of them should slip!
They should slip!! Keep the combo up!
YEAH!!! YEAH!!! YEAH... (Jack is intrigued )
Okay so that's good. That increased my score quite a bit. So I got 3 more to make another big score...
"Explode with 'F'?"
Sounds bad!
But I'm gonna try it I wanna see the "shit-plosion" going on here at the beach.
Alright so I gotta get 40,000
It's the only way
So my- my intention is to make everybody panic and then slip up the roadway so much that no one could possibly get away
And then blast off and explode- oh god I might not make it...
Oh shit!
Might not make- AHH! AHH! OH I CAN EXPLODE ALL I WANT??
GODDAMMIT!
FUUUUU- better, better, better! BETTER- BOMB! YEAH BOMB! BOMB! YEAH!
GO! GO! GO! GO! GO!
YEAH! YEAH! YEAH! YEAH!
SLIP AND FALL!
SLIP AND FALL AND DIE AND SLIP!
SLIP AND SHIT!
SLIP AND FALL!
YEAH! I DID IT NOW!
Yes! okay.. so I got all of them.
I did it! Yeah! Go me!
I didn't think I was gonna
I guess this is all just.. for shits and giggles now
I don't actually need to worry about any of it.
WHEE! RIGHT IN THE POOL! I'M GONNA GO IN THE RING!
Ah shit that's probably a secret..
WOAHHH bloink!
Yep, hole in one I knew it.
Any other secrets that are obvious?
No?
Sorry everybody I had to esplode [explode].
YEE UHHH
*farts*
*Markifart noise* okay.
That should be it! Okay, FINISHED! I'M ALL DONE- with my POOPY on that level!
There's only one more level to go to and I can't imagine it's going to be much different but hey!
It's an adventure ain't it?
OH BOY!
A rollercoaster park on the pier! This will be fantastic!
I'm gonna make my poop go up on the drop tower because apparently there's a tee-pee up there.
I'm just surveying the scenes, studying the level!
YOU DANCE LADY-MAN you dance
I only got two of em'. "Revenge?" How am I getting revenge..?
I don't want revenge!
Here we go.. BOINK!
Okay- YES!
Yes please- sorry!
*sounds of farts and screams*
Sorry! Goddammit! Don't get- DON'T GET CAUGHT ON THAT!!
Get outta there! Stupid piece of poop!
*horrified shit screams*
Panic! Panic!! PANIC IN THE STREETS!!!
*fart*
Oh shit..
Okay... so far so goo!
BYE KID! run awaaaayyyyyy!! Alright.
"De-rail the coaster?" Well that's gonna take some timing!
WOOP!
AHHH SHIT!!! GODDAMMIT! I WAS SO close!
*sounds of farts and screams*
"Dirty job?" OH god I'm sorry.
I didn't really wanna touch that fish suit with my poop...
But life is that way..
BOINK! YEAHHHHHH!!!
"De-rail the coaster!" Got that okay. That's gonna be money in the- WOAH!
"Poopmageddon" I'm sorry.. OH GOD I KILLED ME!
OH JEEZ!!!
I didn't even know that was possible.
Oh- dammit I was supposed to go for the tee-pee. GODDAMMIT i'm not going to make it!
AHHHH! GIVE IT TO MEEE!
(high pitched) OH GOD!! I'M RIGHT THERE! NO!
AH SHIT! Goddammit.
Gimmie that double jump goddammit
HUP!
Albatross! I bet if I hit one of those it would be very beneficial to me.
But I don't have that luxury just yet
Woop! Oh shit..
OH SHIT! Godda- FUCK YOU!
Oh yeah you wanna get away from me? HOW ABOUT THIS ACCURACY OHHHH!!! Fuck you.
Alright.
Got that.. don't know where the other ones are but I got that one.
Alright, this is my last try. If I don't get a 20 combo or a highscore I'm fuuucked.
Dammit I was going to hit a bird!
Well that's going to be something hopefully that gives me some goddamn score.
*panicked screams*
Okay THAT should do it. That should do it. That should do it. That should do it- maybe?
OH COME ON!!!! GET THE- GODDAMMIT THE CO- COMBO WAS RIGHT THERE!!
FUCK ME! Alright... that's it.
I'm a failure!
I'M BAD AT THE.. POOP GAME!
I'M ALL DONE HERE! I GOT ONE!
Alright
So that is Muddy Heights 2
Now I didn't get completionist on any of that but if you total that up, I'm over 100%!
I'm like a 5.2 on the GPA scale! I'm doing great! Even though it's a game about poop...
*some type of indescribable noise*
So, anyway that's all I'm going to play now. You can find this game on Steam.
The only thing is the first game was free, this game costs three bucks so
Play it if you want. You may be able to complete it, but then again, it's a game about poop.
How much honor can that bring you?
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always...
I will see YOU in the next video! Buh-Bye!
*outro music*